dear BuzzFeed my name is Joshua Gonzales
and I'm a senior at University of
Detriot Jesuit High School all my life I
have ain't spread love and hope to
everyone I've encountered this desire to
serve has led my classmates and I to
form a new ministry we call the Paul
bear ministry this ministry's aim is to
serve homeless veterans and other
homeless people who have little to no
loved ones present at their funeral as
pallbearers we ultimately become the
person's family or loved one my
classmates and I believe that everyone
deserves to be honored with dignity and
respect as they are brought to their
final resting place we act as
pallbearers to honor the brave veterans
who sacrificed for us whatever your
calling is I think getting involved in
your community would ultimately change
you for the better we the members of the
Paul bear ministry have acquired so much
from the sentiment of service I feel
truly blessed to have the opportunity to
provide dignity to the people who truly
deserve it what I learned from this
experience is that everyone has the
capacity and capability to do great
things and to pursue their calling no
matter the size of the challenge or the
enormity of the odds finding ways to
help others ultimately benefits us all
thank you thanks for listening Joshua
Gonzalez
you